the new york city mayoral election is in
chaos
after the vote tally numbers jumped all
over the place they just kept changing
there was a seemingly random influx of
over 100 000 votes at one point
you know it just kind of reminded me of
something i don't know deja vu all over
again then the board of elections
website
took down its numbers then the board of
elections
admitted that they had accidentally left
lots and lots
of fraudulent test ballots they left
them in
they weren't fraudulent in that they
weren't cast fraudulently but the test
ballots shouldn't have been in the
machine for the final tally so they were
fraudulent in that regard
they left them in there while the actual
voters went to cast their votes
then some votes were erased and now we
have no idea
who exactly won this was a pretty
strange turn of events
for the most secure voting machines in
human history that are not in any way
susceptible to fraud
or malfunction or abuse and you're not
even allowed to suggest
that there could be modest errors
and yet here we are not just new york
city that's having problems with its
voting machines
maricopa county has just announced a big
problem as well but if you raise
any of these sorts of questions well
watch out
our benevolent overlords in the liberal
establishment will not look too kindly
on that
just ask tucker carlson i'm michael
knowles and this is the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from not colby who
says
this is in response to the nike ad
they're not nike to the nfl ad it's hard
to
keep these woke companies in order the
nfl ad that said the nfl is gay the nfl
is lesbian the nfl is this the nfl is
everything he says if anyone can be
anything
whenever they want then what's the point
of being anything
wow man that is a profound
observation we will get into that
ideology a little bit later
so weird so weird with this election
because
if you ever raise the possibility that
even one
vote was off that one vote was cast that
shouldn't have been cast that maybe
there are sometimes problems with the
machines maybe political campaigns
sometimes try to gain an advantage
you could be de-platformed you could
have the federal government
investigating you because you're an
insurrectionist
but here it is first of all there's
fraud in every single election
lbj won his senate seat and then became
vice president and president
because he stole an election right this
is many many years ago 1948
this happens often the question is
are there enough crazy fraudulent fake
votes in there
to throw the election well here's what's
going on in new york
the election that we're talking about in
new york is actually not the general
election for mayor
it's the primary election but the thing
is new york is a one-party town
so if you win the democratic primary you
just win the election
they had ranked choice voting right
there are sometimes all these little
reformers will always say we need we
need to have ranked choice voting where
you just you vote for your first choice
and your second choice and then if
there's not enough on the first and then
this and then that and this and some too
clever by half
through this entire process into
absolute chaos
so the new york board of elections first
sent out this note
we're aware there's a discrepancy in the
unofficial ranked choice voting round by
round elimination report
we're working with our ranked choice
voting technical staff to identify where
the discrepancy occurred we asked the
public elected officials and candidates
to have patience then they posted
another statement later on which
actually had a typo in it so they had to
take that statement down and they put
another statement up said the board of
elections conducts rigorous and
mandatory pre-qualification testing for
every election
it has been determined that ballot
images used for testing
were not cleared from the election
management system so they just didn't
click refresh
that's at least the excuse we're getting
from the board of elections they just
didn't they didn't like clear their cash
ems produces cast vote records from
ballot images rcv software uses the cvr
to produce unofficial results when the
cast vote records were extracted
it included both test and election night
results
producing approximately 135
000 additional records just mixed in
with all the general votes
but that there was an influx of over a
hundred thousand votes
that shouldn't have been there never
heard of that before right
that's never happened before board staff
has removed all test ballot images from
the system we'll upload election night
results
cross-referencing against election night
reporting okay the board apologizes for
the error and has taken immediate
measures to ensure the most
accurate up-to-date results are reported
are we living in saddams iraq are we
living in bashar assad's
syria can we just we just can't trust
our elections anymore is that it
because you'll just get random influxes
of huge numbers of ballots and it's all
electronic now and so no one knows what
what's going on
that's too bad that's i liked having
relatively secure elections
that's too bad that we have this now
because nobody has any faith in the
board of
board of elections the the two campaigns
for mayor
are obviously at their wit's end here
but it's not just going on in new york
you know there's an audit
of the 2020 election going on in
maricopa county in arizona
i haven't talked too much about the
election audit because i don't want to
talk about it until there's news
so far they're they're just auditing the
vote they're trying to see what's going
on there
obviously as you know were
irregularities in the election i mean in
some cases
the election officials were violating
their state constitutions
and they used the coveted lockdowns as
an excuse irregularities in georgia
places like that and in arizona so in
arizona there's an
audit of the election going on
the democrat secretary of state in
arizona katie hobbs is now saying
that the the voting machines that were
under audit in maricopa county
cannot be used again this is about six
million dollars worth of equipment
because there this woman is afraid that
the people who were doing the audit
may have hacked the machines may have
done something nefarious to
to disrupt elections in the future
do you see the problem with her argument
do you see why her argument is so
so undercuts her previous argument
because
previously we were told that these
machines could not be hacked
we were told nothing could go wrong in
these machines
how dare you you kooky crazy conspiracy
theorist
suggest that something was a little awry
with some of these machines
oh and also we're going to throw out six
million dollars of equipment the minute
maybe a republican touches it maybe we
don't even know who's doing the audit
right we're not saying the
it's not as though the audit is a bunch
of rock-ribbed trump-supporting maga
hat-wearing republicans
there's a team that was brought in to do
the audit but because they touched the
machines
now they're all going to be thrown out
six million dollars worth of gear
if the machines can't be hacked what's
the problem bring them back in and let's
use them again
oh but of course they can i'm not by the
way i'm not even saying that they were
i'm just saying that the arguments that
were put forward
after the election by people who were
just
raising some questions about the
strangest most
irregular election in our history
where a lot of election integrity
measures were
dismantled on the pretense of covid
that is outrageous
that they would now make these same
arguments
you see this kind of sliminess
at all levels of the government right
now it's not just the new york city
board of elections
it's not just the maricopa county
or the arizona democrat secretary of
state who's now undercutting her
arguments from the election
you're seeing this in the nsa tucker
carlson
made a an allegation two nights ago
he said that the nsa was spying on him
he heard about it from a whistleblower
and
uh they are planning to leak his
communications and they want to take a
show off of the air
the nsa this is really shocking that
they would do this they actually did
issue
a statement on this
now the nsa's statement on tucker
carlson first of all it's
pretty strange that the nsa would even
comment on this
if a fox news host or any other news
host for that matter
makes an allegation why would the
national security agency
feel obliged to come out and defend
itself
or maybe not defend itself as you'll see
from the missive
is it because they they feel a little
guilty is it because they know that
where there's smoke there's fire is it
because they fear what tucker carlson
has been told
we know for example that the nsa has
spied on
virtually everybody in the sense that
they're collecting
huge amounts of data and the pretext for
this is they want to make sure
that they monitor uh foreign governments
and people
who have business affairs with
foreigners so
they're collecting all of this data
tucker carlson says
no they're they're specifically looking
at my stuff
so here is the nsa's
denial pay attention to the wording here
on june 28 2021 tucker carlson alleged
that the national security agency has
been quote monitoring our electronic
communications and is planning to leak
them
in an attempt to take this show off the
air this allegation is
untrue tucker carlson has never been an
intelligence target
of the agency and the nsa has never had
any plans to try to take his program off
the air
next paragraph nsa has a foreign
intelligence mission we target foreign
powers to generate insights on foreign
activities
that could harm the united states with
limited exceptions for example an
emergency nsa
may not target a u.s citizen without a
court order that explicitly authorizes
the targeting
now if you're not paying attention to
words you know
there's a great book out right now about
how we need to be really precise about
our language
and it uh it's actually on the the uh
charts this week it's charted
uh we'll we'll get into that a little
bit later the book is called speech
listening following words controlling
minds thank you to those who ordered it
if you're not paying close attention to
words you might say okay they're denying
it right
not so fast in their own denial
they point out that tucker has made
three allegations
the nsa is monitoring monitoring his
communications the nsa is planning to
leak them
the nsa is doing so in an attempt to
take the show off the air
now the the nsa specifically says this
allegation
is untrue which allegation
there are three allegations if
you say this allegation is untrue then
you're lumping them all together
so you're saying no we're not monitoring
your communications and planning to leak
them in order to take your show off the
air so if
any any single part or even two parts of
that
broad allegation could be true and the
nsa could still not be lying by saying
this allegation isn't let's say that
they are monitoring tucker
and they're planning to leak them but
it's not to take his show off the air
well then that allegation's not true
let's say they're monitoring tucker but
they don't really plan to leak them or
take a [ __ ] okay well then that
allegation is not true
even further what they say is tucker
carlson has never been
an intelligence target of the agency
they're not saying they've never spied
on him they're not saying that they're
not spying on him right now
they're saying they're not targeting him
maybe they're targeting someone that
he's speaking to
and oops whoopsie-daisy i guess tucker's
communications are coming through as
well
to me that's and they look at how many
times they use the word target never
been a target of the agency they may not
target a u.s citizen without an order
that authorizes the targeting
why are they using that language the
people who are doing this the spies the
spooks they're actually pretty
sophisticated i don't know if you ever
heard about that
and uh people whose job it is to deceive
are actually pretty good at deceiving
if they were not spying on tucker i bet
they would say that
i bet they would actually just come out
and say it if
they were not either monitoring him
or planning to end or planning to leak
that and or
planning to take a show trying to take a
show off the air i think they would say
that i think they would say
these allegations are untrue
tucker has never been surveilled by the
nsa
tucker is not to me reading this
it is quite clear that the nsa
is in fact conducting surveillance
that involves tucker carlson and
they may or may not be planning to leak
it and i'm sure plenty of people at the
end as they want to take a show off the
air because he's an actual threat to
them
jensaki was asked about this this is
further evidence that the nsa is
obviously looking into tucker carlson
jensaki the white house was asked about
this and she refused to deny it
tucker carlson said that the nsa is
spying on him
is the administration aware of any
or listening efforts on u.s citizens by
the nsa
and is tucker carlson one of them uh
well the
nsa as i think you're well aware i'm
sure everyone's aware uh
everyone on this plane is aware i should
say uh is an entity that focuses on
foreign threats and individuals uh who
are trying attempting to do us harm on
foreign soil so
that is the their uh purview um but uh
beyond that i would point you to the
intelligence community
what what a oh man it's like if you're
gonna
deceive people at least be like the
person at the nsa don't be like jen saki
who doesn't even
who doesn't even really try or doesn't
even come close to succeeding
hey is the nsa spying on tucker carlson
well
um you know the nsa is
uh it's three letter three that's a
three-letter word
um it stands for national security
agency
um it's got employees um they some of
them have pensions
uh and so okay i feel like i've answered
your question
what no i didn't ask what is the nsa i
said is the nsa spying on tucker carlson
well um you know the nsa can and you
know what what they're trying to deflect
to is they're saying
the nsa uh focuses on foreign threats
so hmm what's the implication tucker is
he's colluding with the russians or the
ukrainians
or whatever he's or anybody he's this is
the same
old story same stuff different day
the reason the reason that the federal
government had to spy on the trump
campaign
had to spy on its political opponents is
because
they were colluding with the russians
okay well where's the proof what what
crime did they commit they all
um
several years long millions and millions
of dollars spent to just
try to prove anything like they got him
right there's got to be some connection
trump ate borscht one time a few years
ago didn't he no they didn't even have
that
they didn't even have that but that's
the excuse we have to make sure he could
be
he he talked to his falafel court driver
down the street that's if he's talking
to a foreigner
got to get him pretty quick unless the
nsa and the white house can do better
than this
i think the only conspiracy theory is
that the nsa is not spying on tucker
corals and they've they've all but
admitted that
just dodging the question saki
you know she i'm glad she's not that
good at her job
because it makes the biden agenda
and the disparity between what the biden
administration wants what the american
people want it makes it so clear
the american people they don't care
about this bloated government spying on
them and just collecting dirt on them
all the time and undermining their
political will and throwing open their
borders and shipping their manufacturing
jobs overseas and
locking them down no no that's not it
you know what they really care about
you know what middle america really
cares about electric
car charging stations and making them
more readily available
people across the country people who
care deeply about addressing our climate
crisis know the components of what's
in this package which the president
considers a down payment not the end
a down payment so 500 000 electric
vehicle
charging stations nationwide that's what
this would help support with a focus on
our highways
and rural and disadvantaged communities
it would help buy more than 35 000
electric
school buses yeah now that's what we
want
that's what the rural and disadvantaged
communities want is
500 000
chevy volt charging stations or whatever
oh no tesla i guess tesla's which that's
what that's what
rural disadvantaged america needs is
more tesla ports
and and more electric school buses
that's that's what they care about right
i don't think so
but they they always go back to the
environmentalism issue the climate issue
because it's as grandiose and ideas and
you can't pin it down also right it's
global cooling it's global warming i
write about this in the book
it's climate change it's climate crisis
it's climate catastrophe
it affects the whole wide world we've
got it you've got to surrender
your political power and your political
rights to
the u.n or the wto or the imf or the
paris agreement or whatever
because the whole world is under threat
aoc right now is proposing
that we take 70 billion
billion with a b and spend it
on a civilian climate core
and so the question that we have is we
have a student loan crisis a housing
crisis a climate crisis
how on earth can we possibly overcome
this
and i think one of the ways that we
overcome it is by being one of the most
unionized workforces and unionized
generations in american history
by collecting our power as workers in
the economy
we can take our futures back and what's
important about a civilian climate corps
is that it's an on-ramp and can function
as an on-ramp
to unionization and when we plug this in
with union labor but it's going to
require
putting us to work in the externalities
of climate change
it's going to require it's the crisis
don't you feel the crisis
don't you feel aren't you full of
anxiety at the
crisis of the sun monster don't you and
that's why we need a 70 billion
civilian climate corps what this is
modeled after quite clearly
is the ccc new deal pro right it's
there's the ccc civilian climate core
the ccc was a new deal program
uh developed by franklin roosevelt there
were many new deal programs they all had
a bunch of silly letters it was the ccc
there was the wpa
actually at the time there was a
barbershop music society
they called itself spebska the society
for the preservation encouragement of
barbershop quartet singing in america
as a joke on all of these new deal
programs what happened during the new
deal
was the government created a bunch of
gigantic bloated programs
to just employ people to do nothing to
dig holes to just to not really do
anything productive
but the new deal and we forget about it
now because it was so long ago and the
right never figured out how to overcome
it
the new deal fundamentally reordered
the country the the new deal
fundamentally changed the relationship
between the citizen
and the state and the federal government
and
the the right has never never recovered
from it they fought against it
until about the late 1950s early 1960s
and then they realized it was never
going to be overcome and and
since that time that the right has
really been on the back foot that the
left has
really dominated america and so what aoc
is she's using this
preposterous issue of the sun monster
and she's saying because of the
the invisible imaginary you can't quite
see it but it's definitely there
urgent dire threat of of
sunshine we need to further
reorder the relationship between the
citizen and the state government the
federal government
and bloat our federal government because
money is power and employment is power
and and
uh she's she's trying to she actually
directly compares this
to to these various other programs that
have gone on since
franklin roosevelt and it's really smart
it's a very smart political strategy
that will really put the right on the
back foot if they go along with this
really hope they don't hope the squishes
don't go along with it you know someone
who's not a squish clarence thomas
clarence thomas great man there's a
great movie about him called created
equal
it was on amazon and then amazon decided
to cancel it
during black history month isn't that
strange
it's a very important black jurist or
the most important jurist left on the
supreme court
one of the one of the two gets him and
alito basically are the only
actual conservatives left on the court
and so great movie we didn't want it to
get canceled
here at the daily wire so we just we
just bought it now we're streaming it
you can go check out
created equal at dailywire.com subscribe
get 20
off your new membership with code
justice also too often
heroes do not receive the recognition
they deserve they they fade into the
historical archives and they are
forgotten
which is why the daily wire is changing
things our new podcast america's
forgotten heroes illuminates the intense
and action-packed stories
of seven men who fought against all odds
to make america as free as it is today
actually a bit freer than it is today
we're kind of on the downswing today but
they
they really did fight and did their job
in their time
from john paul jones the father of the
us navy to frank
luke the 21 year old ace pilot who took
down 18 german aircraft in 18 days
during world war ii these brave men
saved our country at some of its darkest
hours and transformed the country for
the future
subscribe now to america's forgotten
heroes on apple podcast spotify or
anywhere you might listen
so you can catch first episode which
drops tomorrow thursday july 1st
wow july already tomorrow then one new
action-packed episode drops each day
through the fourth of july weekend and
into next week for a total of seven
episodes
too many heroes never receive the
recognition they deserve sharing their
stories with you on
independence day the real independence
day is our small tribute to their
heroism
if you like what you hear leave a
five-star review and help share these
incredible stories thanks for listening
thank you to the heroes that made these
podcasts possible we'll be right back
climate change is the perfect issue
for the left because it's everything and
it's nothing getting back to the comment
at the top of the show getting back to
what the nfl said the nfl is gay
the nfl is transgender first of all just
you can't be both of those at the same
time right those are mutually exclusive
concepts that have
different understandings of human nature
and different understandings of sex so
you can't nfl is a lesbian
the nfl is well you also can't be a
lesbian if you're transgender the nfl is
powerful the nfl the nfl is everything
it's everything it can't be everything
because some things are different some
things are opposites
so if you're if you're two up you can't
be two opposites simultaneously that's
just good old uncle aristotle
the law of non-contradiction goodness
gracious
but climate change is everything when
when the weather is cold it's climate
change when the weather is warm it's
climate change when the polar ice caps
are melting it's climate change when the
polarized caps are actually gaining ice
so it's
climate change it's all climate change
and it's a crisis by the way
the world is going to end according to
prince charles in the uk the world
already ended about a year and a half
ago he did he said this
a few years ago he said the world's
going to end in 18 months it's going to
be it's going to be too late at that
point
it's too late to do anything in 18
months okay but now they're still saying
we need to do something it's too late
forget about it it's over remember aoc
famously said two or three years ago the
world's going to end in 12 years
uh oh got about nine years left don't
lose track
something tells me in about nine years
they're gonna say it's another it's
going to be another 10 or
10 years do you remember in the 70s i
actually write about this and speechless
in the 70s the population bomb this was
a related issue
it still had to do with the environment
but it was in a different way than the
sun monster
the population bomb was going to lead to
mass starvation by the 80s
90s was inevitable it was just going to
happen you got to deal with it that's
why we need forced
abortion and forced contraception which
actually they did follow in india and
china to
horrific horrific crimes and then it
just it just didn't happen now 50 years
later
the world population has doubled were
fatter than ever before just didn't
doesn't matter still crisis still urgent
and every single problem is
climate change you know they did this
when they were trying to pass the
infrastructure bill
they said you know everything is
infrastructure
paid family leave that's infrastructure
of raising the minimum wage that's
infrastructure
that delicious bag of m m's over there
that's that's infrastructure we need to
you please pass me those m
m's so they're doing this with climate
change now the biden energy secretary
is is now claiming there was that awful
story of the building collapse in
florida really really terrible thing
the biden energy secretary is now
claiming
suggesting that climate change may have
caused the building collapse
given what we know about the changing
climate given that we've seen an
increase in these so-called
extraordinary tides
and the impact that that can have in
areas like
south florida do you think that climate
could have played a role in that
building's collapse well obviously we
don't know fully but we do know that the
seas are rising i mean we know that
we're losing
inches and inches of beaches not just in
florida but
all around um you know lake michigan
where i'm from they
you know we've seen the loss of beaches
because the
the waters are rising so you know this
is a phenomenon that will continue
whether it we'll have to wait to see
what the analysis is for this
building but the issue about resiliency
and making sure we adapt to this
changing climate that's going to mean
levees need to be built that means sea
walls need to be built that means
infrastructure needs to be built
oh it's infrastructure again okay we got
back to infrastructure
do you think because there's a big
ticker at the bottom climate crisis this
is all this is what cnn does
i mean this is what corporate media does
generally but it's especially with cnn
that's the crisis be on edge
vote for democrats do you think
that climate might have caused
this building to collapse do you think
that climate might have caused every
tragedy that's happened
well maybe
maybe yeah maybe it's like
do you think ghosts caused it that's
basically what do you think was aliens
it's like that guy in the meme from the
history channel
who built the pyramids uh i'm not saying
it was aliens but it was aliens
uh hey how did um how did anything
happen ever
well uh it was aliens the climate change
is the new aliens
that's that's the answer real it's
really offensive to say also because do
you know what caused the building
collapse
uh poor maintenance of the building and
i think people are there actually are
people who are responsible for this and
they should have to pay price and it's
not just
what is climate what is climate
climate is everything right it's all the
it's every physical thing that we've got
going on
around us it's like the nfl climate is
the nfl
now speaking of this awful awful event
in florida
joe biden was addressing reporters the
other day it's a rare occurrence when
biden addresses reporters
and he forgot to address this issue of
the building collapse he just seemed to
forget what had happened and
this was a really bad thing i haven't
covered it too much on the show
because it's just sad i don't think
there's too much of a political angle
here it's just like a really really sad
thing
and so joe biden was supposed to talk
about this he forgot to so kamala harris
had to remind him
i've got to get helicopters
will you travel to florida sir can we
ask you about florida what you've
learned
oh yes i apologize yes thank you my
president
uh i've spoken with coincidentally
the mayor of miami-dade
was in my office yesterday and i talked
to her today
not about that obviously and so i had a
long discussion with her today
i've also spoken with we've come in
contact with the congresswoman
debbie wasserman schultz who has that
district this does remind me of a moment
the very very end of of reagan's tenure
there was a moment where he seemed to
forget what he was
saying or what what he was talking about
and there you can see it on video
nancy kind of subtly turns to him and
just says doing the best we can
and then reagan you know great great
orator great performance
well we're doing the best we can well i
and it was the moment where people
started to say gosh is he
did he have a senior moment now
revisionists have gone back and said oh
yeah reagan was
just absolutely in the throes of
alzheimer's during his whole presidency
that's preposterous ronald reagan ended
the cold war during his presidency he
was extremely sharp
for virtually all of his presidency he
was at that time the oldest
guy ever elected president and maybe he
had a senior moment or two
no question joe biden
doesn't just have a senior moment or two
it's not just one moment where he kind
of goes a little absent-minded way we're
doing
it's it's like every time he talks and
it seems to be getting worse
and it's a lot different ronald reagan
is giving some impromptu remarks versus
joe biden at a formal press conference
and the vice president needs to tell him
what's going on he's been
he's got a lot of quirks lately you've
seen he's he's also fallen into another
very strange rhetorical trap where he
starts
to emphasize something by by an
exaggerated stage whisper he just did
this the other day talking about
taxes and people say well that's a
giveaway
hey guys i think it's time to give
ordinary people a tax
break the wealthy are doing fine
i mean it i mean it
why is this not a tax break
for working folks when the stuff we give
to the super wealthy
are called tax breaks oh
okay so that was weird it's weird when
he doesn't he leans and goes hey
he's got his weird creepy biden eyes
popping out of his head we hey
why do i quit it's called a tax break so
but he
recovered there was it sort of worked
well enough sometimes it hasn't worked
well just the other day he was also
speaking to reporters and he he
whispered a little too hard a little too
i wrote the bill on the environment
why would i not be for it
[Applause]
book a book it's
that that was not not quite as effective
as when he was talking about
the taxes now i point all this out
the senior moment the weird whispering
stuff that losing his train of thought
because i i'm not just trying to make
fun of him it's perfectly fine to have a
laugh at old joe's expense
but it's because regardless of all that
he's very effective he is and we just
we we mock him or we dismiss him at our
own peril
the guy is very effective he's survived
in politics
for 50 years he has been at the top
levels of american politics for half a
century
he beat out a lot of other democrats
this go around
who were much younger and more
impressive than he is
he's very effective and his those these
senior moments and this apparent
incompetence
i think is in some ways a helpful
distraction
for the liberal establishment that acts
through him because he just gives them
whatever they want he basically walked
into the white house
and he said okay state department here's
here's the keys to foreign policy
okay liberal establishment here's the
keys to whatever economic policy or
trade
and he just said i'm going to be
watching matlock over in the corner
and that's very very effective it's why
we've now
all the gains we had made in the middle
east gone the gains we had made
negotiating with china gone
joe's a huge fan of china joe has
famously said
repeatedly that it's good for the united
states for china to get bigger and
stronger and richer
i don't think that's true i think china
is our number one enemy
but the liberal establishment love
that's why they let china into the world
trade organization that's why they
refuse to blame china for the
coronavirus that's why they've helped
china cover up
their creation of the coronavirus and
they're
in their own cover-up of the coronavirus
and
american corporations are helping out
too but as i said this is why i don't
just say
the government i don't just talk about
big government i talk about the liberal
establishment because that includes
the universities the elected government
the administrative government
big tech and lower education
and woke corporations the ceo of nike
john donahue was just asked about
his company's business in china china
violates
trade agreements china aggresses on our
assets all over the world china
started the coronavirus and then covered
it up and shut down the entire world
china uses slave labor uh
to by the way to manufacture products
that we all use
and so he was asked about this and they
said hey don't you have any problem
doing business with china
and john donahue said during a call with
the wall street journal
that nike quote nike is a brand that
is of china and for china
all right all right at least look he's
not saying the
the nfl line and it's everything nike is
for everything nike is it no he's saying
it's
of china and it's for china
okay i thought nike was an american
brand
i thought it was of america and for
america
or at least it's of america but it's for
the whole world but no
no the nike ceo is telling us it's of
china and for china okay
so then the next time we sanction
chinese companies i think we should
sanction
nike i think that the next time we stop
doing business with chinese companies
next time we start slapping big tariffs
on chinese companies
i think we should slap big tariffs on
nike stop doing business with nike
you want to be a chinese company that's
fine you should be treated like a
chinese company
i am sick and tired of republicans
carrying water for companies that hate
our country
we know that nike hates our country
their spokesman
is famous not because he was
particularly good at football but
because he famously hates our country
and disrespected
the symbol of our country on our playing
fields
and got nike to shut down a a running
shoe
that featured the american revolutionary
flag on it the betsy ross flag
they shut it down can't do that because
they hate america okay
if you hate america then i think maybe
america should hate you
okay i think it's got to be kind of a
two-way street i don't think we can just
get run over
by these zillion dollar companies that
that milk us for our money and then
undermine our country every chance we
get and in this case
explicitly say our loyalty is to
america's greatest
enemy on the world stage
we should we should not just stop
wearing nike i don't wear nike shoes
if nike made sockless loafers i would
consider wearing them but they don't
so i don't i'm not just saying we should
boycott nike i'm not just saying we
should stop shopping
there i'm saying we should exercise our
political power
to punish nike because nike is siding
with our enemy
against our country and we have a
political i don't care what
abstract insane economic theory from the
1970s
you you are enthralled with
i think people are increasingly not so
enthralled with those theories
but even if you've made a total idol out
of the free market or you made a total
idol out of gdp or whatever
the company is siding with our enemies
and so i
don't want to do business with them and
i don't want our country to do business
with them
the american people have a right to
shape our country
the country should not just be run by
liberal elites
right now you have a small number of
liberal elites relatively small number
of liberal elites
who make most of the decisions and we
don't really have very much say about it
and if we raise any problems with it
they'll probably be spying on us like
they are on tucker carlson
and the american people of all shades of
all sexes of all
geographies they are pushing back
against this kind of thing they're
pushing back against
critical race theory right that is now
sort of the lightning rod
because it is the the expression of
these insane vile
racial ideologies that tell
americans tell white americans and
anyone who agrees with any conservatives
that they are vile so black people who
agree with conservatives
hispanic people agree tell tell them
they are vile
vicious racist that this country is
terrible there the ideology being pushed
in these schools is the ideology of nike
you're going to make more nikes
america's a terrible rotten place and we
got to overcome it we got to hate
ourselves and we got to suck up to china
this is the kind of stuff you know now
they're trying to deny they're saying
the people who are pushing
all of these various critical studies
you know blackness studies whiteness
studies critical race theory
all of these guys they're they're not
really saying
that whites are terrible and whiteness
is evil and all whites are racist
they are here's hebron kennedy ibram
kennedy is the most famous one of these
race hustlers probably in the country
today
here he is on cbs news calling all
whites racist i mean as robin
you know talked about it it is critical
for for white people for people uh in
general
to stop denying their their racist ideas
to stop denying the ways in which
policies have benefited them to stop
denying
their racism and to realize that
actually the heartbeat of racism itself
is denial and the sound of that
heartbeat is i'm not racist
this is the climate change of racial
politics
by which i mean climate change
it's it's defining quality is that it is
unfalsifiable
any phenomenon can be used
and interpreted to
justify climate change or to to be
attributed to climate change
it gets colder climate change warmer
climate change stays the same climate
change
this is why it's not a very good
scientific theory because you you can't
disprove it well it's the same thing
with this insane racial stuff
what ibram kennedy is saying is if white
people admit that they're racist
they're racist if white people deny that
they're racist
that's even further proof that they're
racist this is
called begging the question this is what
happens when you assume your own
conclusion you begin with the premise as
hebrew candy does
that all white people are racist
therefore if you admit it okay good
therefore if you deny it yup there you
go
conclusion all white people are racist
it's not not a very good argument
one of the many reasons that sort of
things should not be taken seriously but
that is what is being taught and i think
ordinary americans
of all races are looking at this and
saying no
that's stupid and it's evil and it's
destroying our country and we don't want
our kids being poisoned with
these idiotic ramblings of a con artist
like ibram candy or robin deangelo
and by the way i say this as a civil
rights icon
okay i don't know if you saw it i don't
know if you were perusing amazon
but right now my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds is
the number one
book in civil rights and liberties
right now it is beating at number two
and number three and number four is
ibrahim kendy and robyn d'angelo but
number one
is michael knowles and i'm just very
pleased
that amazon is finally acknowledging my
role as
the preeminent civil rights leader in
the country
that's good and so i tell you i give you
permission
as people who care about civil rights
do not listen to ibram kendi and robin
deangelo they're the number two and
number three recognized civil rights
leaders in the country but i am number
one
and so i'm telling you that they are
idiots and they are poisoning your
children and our country
you should not i hate to be so mean
about it
but it's a it's a crisis it's a real
threat and so no one
should pay attention to their
nonsensical ramblings
you should instead read speechless
controlling words controlling minds it's
really ugly
ugly stuff going on in the race hustling
these days i'll tell you a headline i
just saw
princeton university has just admitted
the largest percentage ever
of students of color
by or after i don't want to imply
causation here but they've admitted the
largest percentage of students of color
after they got rid of standardized tests
so that's not if i they've now admitted
68
of students who self-identify as a
person of color you wonder now because
grievance carries a currency
and because there's legal discrimination
in this country against whites
and asians on behalf in favor of
blacks and hispanics you you wonder how
many of these
people who are self-identifying as
students of color have
like one one zillionth
north african dna and they say see i'm
i'm black i'm african
i'm an african-american they're you know
they're from south africa or something
they look dutch but they say no i'm
african-american elon musk now is
african-american who knows
you wonder about that you wonder how
many of them are like the british guy
who now
says that he's a korean guy but also if
i were a student of color
and i were admitted to this university
after they got rid of standardized
testing
i would be a little offended because i
was like oh they
they're telling me that i can't actually
compete they're telling me i can't
actually
be as smart they're telling me i can't
actually understand the same sorts of
things and so
they had to in order to get to the
conclusion that they won of having more
non-white students they've got to get
rid of all the standards
that's and that's offensive it was very
offensive to clarence thomas actually
that's why you should go check out that
movie
clarence thomas goes to yale law school
he's one of the most brilliant jurists
in the country
but he realized he had trouble getting a
job after law school because everyone
thought he was an affirmative action
case
in the case of clarence thomas he
actually is this outstanding jurist
but that's the that is the taint of of
this sort of legal discriminations this
racial ugly
ugly racial politics you're seeing a lot
of standards eroding
right now in nevada you're seeing a man
win miss nevada okay
but that's look that erosion of
standards
is a topic for another day we've got to
pause it there i'm michael knowles as
the michael knowles shall see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy bourie our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matte wall show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you your family our country
not just politics but culture faith
current events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show